will take five topics then the bank will
drop a beat we'll do a three-star rep
and let's come to the kind of front of
the room we'll divide into two if you're
on this side which is like a rapper
okay great yeah no that's uh I'd love to
hear a rap song about sex Chris there's
been so few of those now I I don't want
to you know probe too deeply that's the
bad way to put it I don't want to I
don't want to make you uncomfortable and
ask you to be more specific in in your
tastes but I would like it to be more
specific for the context of the wrap so
when it comes to sex what are we talking
about what aspect of sex are we focusing
on
doggy style good okay calm down Madam
I'm getting aroused uh
doggy style sex and uh uh give me one
adjective to describe it
hot
hot okay great hot dog
are you single uh
if you are in this Enclave here what
would you like to hear a rap about
Silicon Valley Bank okay you said that
with the depressed tone of someone who
had money in Silicon Valley Bank
this side of the room so far we have
Silicon Valley Bank and hot doggy style
sex oh yeah
people watching on the live stream I
apologize that you're now streaming hot
doggy style sex this is awkward if
someone walks in this side of the front
what would you like a wrap that
artificial intelligence are you involved
in the sector
a little bit oh what do you do
a data scientist cool I'd love to date a
scientist hey
um
[__] love puns what's wrong with you
uh okay cool a data scientist and
artificial intelligence let's come to
the the back of the room it's your time
to shine so far pretty grounded pretty
you know every day you can really take
it one step further go crazy what you
want to rap about
what did you say uh my tiny voiced
person at the back
a mosaic wall was that
yes how how erudite
um yeah are you Grecian perhaps where
are you from
Boston now okay
yeah not Grecian yeah
do you have are there mosaics in Boston
yeah we [__] smashed things up but
you know you can put them back together
a mosaic wall final section I want this
to be the best one so that doesn't mean
you know we can you know it's no
pressure but we want it to be super
great What's it gonna be
New York's rats are yes there is one of
those isn't it now londoners in this
city they pay someone a lot of money to
deal with the rats I don't know if
you've noticed it's not working
um they are they are everywhere okay New
York's rats are a mosaic wall hot doggy
style sex I'm gonna keep saying it in
that voice artificial intelligence and
data science and of course uh Silicon
Valley Bank well
um red and Jeremy I would love you to
provide me with some sort of musical
accompaniment they're going to make up a
beat I want to make of a wrap it will be
as good as the suggestions that's my
excuse
okay
when it comes to sleigh and rodents the
best by far the lady by Eric Adams the
rat Czar spell it CZ or maybe TS when it
comes to getting Vermin yeah she's the
best don't trifle don't mess your you
need to hide in the subway tunnels Maybe
in your hole cause she's coming best
believe while I rap put the cheese on
the Trap and she Splat that rat gathered
them in sacks chasing with the dogs run
them off to New Jersey is kind of odd
make sure they're never coming back on
trash day I see the rap and his nor in
his way through several layers like
seven ply so many fish's teeth inside
and I cried with pride and Glee I'm like
New York City make sure the Vermin get
out they're not pretty but what about
the other stuff we'd be troubled by
pigeons are basically the Rats of the
sky anyway we move over on a tank if you
don't put your money in the Silicon bank
then you're okay yeah you're pretty sure
svb then the other one was signature and
then First Republic got bought like
today get your money out right away I'm
not trying to start a run like a
wonderful life I'm not saying you should
get it out after this twice remove your
deposits I'm pretty sure if you've got
not a lot then it's federally insured
like quarter of a mill that's a lot but
if you're in Silicon bank it's not not
hot now Silicon Valley you should really
warn used to be famous for the porn but
now there's a new dawn with the aiuc
data scientists saying chat GPT three
four and mid-journey you need to make
sure you're getting early you could
invest get Bill Gates to give advice Sam
Bachmann free that's a guy who's not
nice he was [__] [__] up he was
causing all the loss AI one day will be
your boss and you'll be there like I'm
an AI hater I'm the person who used to
control the data and look at all the
info but now it slays me over here yes
the Wall's so crazy take a beautiful
thing you've got a planet tiny little
pieces of clay ceramic and if you glaze
them and paint them with the paintbrush
if you're in Boston yeah there ain't
much but back in the day you would
really show them in the beautiful Greek
Villas or the Romans they're looking
there this is stained glass so you just
have to imagine this bit of that oh
little squares made into a shape so
beautiful British people we take we
would take the mosaics put them in a
museum so all the Queen's subjects could
really see him now the last thing I'm so
glad you shouted next second suggestion
you were like please sex sex sex sex sex
just three simple letters okay foreplay
to get the lady much wetter than she was
before don't wanna leave her crying if
you don't antidepressants then it's
[__] trying that's what Eric said yes
I can't come but if you do it this way
not up the bum but from Return angle
bend the lady over she's like oh yeah
you should really show you a good time
do the style that canines mate Beastie
Boys used to say this it's so great I
call it doggy style yes I do it a lot
you've got to get the lady in the little
Squat and when you ejaculate once you've
shot you ask her how it was and she
replies hot
foreign